from vengeful fathers of parasitic
aliens some famous movies just come
before their time these horror movies
are the scream of the crop of box office
flops
the sun deal and Lawrence Fishburne LED
horror Event Horizon is nothing short of
an unforgettable descent into hellish
Madness the film follows the crew of a
Starship in the year 2047 which is
tasked with answering the distress
signal of another space-faring vessel
called The Event Horizon this mysterious
ship has suddenly disappeared seven
years prior drawing its maiden voyage
and has now eerily reappeared in orbit
around Neptune while the crew finds on
the Event Horizon is the stuff of
nightmares the crew has been massacred
and the ship's visual records to pick
the crew members losing their minds and
engaging in sexual activity and body
mutilation the rescue crew then begins
seeing horrific hallucinations that
recall their own individual histories
the mysteries of the event horizon or
revolve around its strange disappearance
experimental space travel effectively
took the ship to another dimension hell
where we're going we won't need eyes to
see
director Paul W S Anderson was riding
high after the success of the 99 95
movie adaptation of the popular video
game Mortal Kombat but shifting from
PG-13 material to R-rated horror proved
to be financially detrimental for the
director upon its 1997 release Event
Horizon only grossed nearly 42 million
dollars worldwide against a 60 million
dollar budget critically it was panned
for its excessive Gore according to the
Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
however horror fans began flocking to
the film in droves as years passed
causing multiple home additions to be
released and spurring on another
examination of the film's critical
standing
even casual film fans around at the time
can record a stir generated by The Sixth
Sense the 1999 film about a young boy
who can see dead people but director M
Night Shyamalan on the map however there
was another film release that year
featuring a protagonist who could see
the dead and it was Faithfully
overshadowed by the swelling popularity
of The Sixth Sense in stir with Echoes
Tom witsky played by Kevin Bacon is a
blue-collar phone line repair man
working in the suburbs of Chicago he's a
skeptic of the supernatural but agrees
to allow his sister-in-law to hypnotize
him drawing the alleged hypnosis she
suggests that Tom be more open-minded
from this point forward he begins seeing
visions of a ghostly Apparition of a 17
year old girl who wants Tom to help her
complete some unfinished business while
the film wasn't a complete Financial
failure it wasn't a success either and
only garnered a 21 million dollar gross
according to Box Office Mojo the film
actually received praise from critics
thanks to its great curse tension-filled
story and Solid Source material real as
it's based on horror Master Richard
Matheson's 1958 novel a stir with Echoes
however many noted that it was just
released too closely to the sixth sense
since it came out just a month after
shyamalan's hit the film simply suffered
from hitting the big screen at the wrong
time but once a sixth sense phenomenon
died down horror fans were able to
ReDiscover star of Echoes after its home
video release despite its middling
Rotten Tomato scores Stir of Echoes
continues to be a subject of discussion
for film critics and horror fans alike
based on Jeff vandermeer's novel of the
same name the Alex Garland directed
sci-fi psychological horror Annihilation
perplexed moviegoers with this enigmatic
story and underlying philosophy the film
posits her alien contact might not be
the cut and dry scenario we've always
envisioned a meteor crash lands on Earth
and creates an ever-expanding Zone the
government has dubbed the Shimmer those
who have gone inside the Shimmer haven't
returned until one soldier named Kane
played by Oscar Isaac finally Durst
however he's been affected by the zone
and enters a coma his wife Lena played
by Natalie Portman is a biologist and
volunteers to join an expedition into
the Shimmer in hopes of finding answers
about her husband's condition when did
he arrive back home
I want to see a lawyer you're not going
to be able to see a lawyer what the
group finds is that life inside this
Shimmer has been mutated horrific animal
monstrosities attacked the group they
even find the bodies of those who have
gone before albeit heavily disfigured as
Lena makes her way to Ground Zero she
begins to learn a bit about herself and
her relationship with her husband while
Annihilation may have been a critical
darling for its provocative themes the
audience says simply didn't show up with
a production budget of 40 million
dollars and a worldwide gross of 43
million dollars the studio likely lost
money once marketing costs were factored
in Publications like Indie wire and the
guardian argue that the movie suffered
because of the Studio's fear of not
seeing immediate returns which meant it
didn't get time to build an audience
however thanks to the source materials
popularity among sci-fi readers and the
films released on Netflix overseas
Annihilation found a second chance at
life with its streaming release
if you have a tough stomach then maybe
you can handle the grizzly imagery of
the 2015 Western horror bone Tomahawk
it's the 1890s and Sheriff Franklin hunt
learns that a tribe of cannibalistic
cave dwellers who have been shunned by
other indigenous communities are the
likely culprits of the recent
kidnappings of three people the sheriff
played by Kurt Russell said felt on a
rescue mission with local Gunslinger
John Bruder played by Matthew Fox and
Deputy chicori played by Richard Jenkins
also along for the journey as he injured
Arthur O'Dwyer played by Patrick Wilson
whose wife is one of the people that has
been captured what they encounter
however is the stuff of nightmares well
some horror fans can enjoy over-the-top
Gore in a campy slasher the violence in
this film is visceral grimy and jarring
don't say you weren't one bone Tomahawk
received critical praise and even has a
certified fresh rating on Rotten
Tomatoes most enjoyed the Slow Burn that
paid off with the intense tension and
horrors of the third act it's hard to
say that this film was a total flub
considering getting he received a
limited theatrical release that made
over 475 thousand dollars in ticket
sales according to the numbers for a
release plan like this it was always
intended to play the long game while the
ticket sales were Mighty low home video
sales spiked due to Good Word of Mouth
which according to the guardian ensured
that the film was ultimately profitable
in the long run
when you hear the name Peter Jackson you
likely think of his big budget epics
like the Lord of the Rings trilogy or
King Kong for this reason many have been
left in the dark about Jackson's zombie
horror comedy film brain dead which was
released in North America with the title
Dead Alive the film relishes in its
namesake and brings buckets full of Gore
and gross out practical effects to its
ridiculous story Lionel played by
Timothy Baum is a young man who was
taking care of his mother Vera played by
Elizabeth Moody unfortunately for Lionel
Vera is extremely overbearing and wants
to dominate Lionel's life at every turn
but Lionel lands a date with a young
lady he takes to the Wellington Zoo his
mother follows them while there she is
bitten by a repulsive creature Vera soon
succumbs to an illness stemming from the
bites that turns her into a zombie she
winds up infecting countless others and
poor Lionel is left to deal with the
burgeoning undead situation the film
only grows 242
623 at the North American box office
according to Box Office Mojo however the
film became such a cult hit with horror
fans that it has continually been
released on several platforms including
VHS LaserDisc DVD and Blu-ray according
to the Hollywood Reporter Jackson wants
to use his super technologically
advanced wetter digital VFX Studio to
remaster the film for a 4K release Dead
Alive is an absolute blast but just make
sure you're not eating anything while
viewing this romp
the slasher sub-genre of horror wouldn't
be what it is today without John
Carpenter's iconic 1978 film Halloween
the movie created a Larger than Life
movie monster in the form of the Twisted
serial killer Michael Myers the Indie
film's popularity prompted a sequel that
was released in 1981 and directed by
Rick rosenthorne with Michael Myers
established as a symbol of horror one
would think that a three core would
center around his terrifying return
instead the filmmakers and producers
opted for an anthology approach to the
Halloween Series where each film would
tell a different story on Halloween
Carpenter felt that Michael Meyer's
story was complete with Halloween 2. so
Halloween 3 focus on a new cast of
characters and a Michael Myers free Tale
the problem is that the franchise
already had two films under its belt
featuring Michael Myers audiences had
inextricably linked the killer with the
Halloween name once moviegoers realized
he wasn't featured in the third
installment the film's box office
performance waned significantly Box
Office Mojo reports that Halloween 3
received a poultry 14mm million dollar
gross compared to the 25 million dollars
of its predecessor and 47 million
dollars of the first film such a
significant decrease in profit prompted
filmmakers to revert back to Michael
Myers with a fourth installment
[Music]
Halloween 3 digital slasher genre
entirely and embraced a different kind
of horror that straddles a line between
the Supernatural and sci-fi haunted
masks imprinted with the villainous
company's microchip wreak havoc on an
unsuspecting population in recent years
fans have returned to the film praising
its unique narrative the film has seen
new releases including a 4K release from
Shout Factory
director Sam Raimi is no stranger to
horror but his Evil Dead franchise
counted among one of the most beloved of
the genre in this installment we follow
Ash played by Bruce Campbell a demon
slaying chainsaw wielding hero whose ego
Rivals only his own pension for survival
while on 1981's Evil Dead started out as
a small indie horror film it quickly
gained traction and led to the 1986
sequel Evil Dead 2 dead by Dawn which
moved from Pure horror to a horror
comedy combination that fans have
affectionately dubbed a Splat stick it
was only a matter of time before the
franchise continued which it did with
1993's Army of Darkness the film bid
sash against the deadites of old in a
medieval civilization ashmas live up to
his name as a prophesized champion and
Vanquish evil while the film had the
biggest budget of the original trilogy
it didn't exactly bring home the bacon
during its theatrical run despite its 11
million dollar budget Army of Darkness
only pulled in a measly 11.5 million
dollars in North America and 21.5 5
million dollars worldwide still like the
film that started it all Army of
Darkness became a cult classic in fact
Army of Darkness on home video became a
Gateway for a whole new generation to
discover the Evil Dead films eventually
fan ferva pushed interested parties into
making a successful Reboot film in 2013
as well as a Stars TV series Ash vs Evil
Dead there's more evil dead on the way
as Evil Dead risers scheduled to hit
theaters in the spring of 2023
there's nothing quite like a good
old-fashioned story of Revenge and
murder a 1988's pumpkin head serves a
Vengeance nice and cold Ed Harley played
by Lance Henriksen is a widower and
single parent of his young son Billy
played by Matthew Hurley one day while
Ed is away for work a group of Misfit
teens begin to pick on Billy they
accidentally fatally injured the boy and
flee the scene when Ed returns he finds
sister sees son and soon learns who
killed Billy The Grieving Ed visits a
witch and asks her to help him seek
vengeance upon the teens he called upon
this thing
a man's name and that man he'd be
Avenged
she summons a demonic creature known as
pumpkin head who systematically hunts
and kills the teens one by one this is
another film that suffered because it
was released in a limited number of
theaters which led to Pumpkin Head only
grossing four million dollars at the box
office as a result however the film
eventually found Success Through home
video releases as new fans discovered
this terrifying and emotional film
directed by Stan Winston a special
effects Mastermind behind aliens and the
Terminator its home video success
enabled the film to receive a handful of
sequels which unfortunately don't
remotely live up to the original film
George A Romero the father of the modern
zombie is a Titan among horror fandom
1968's Knight of the Living Dead became
memorable for its graphic violence and
depiction of a world besieged by the
cannibalistic Undead in many ways it was
the first of its kind the horror Maestro
succeeded that first outing with 1978's
Dawn of the Dead a zombie horror base in
a mall Rife with biting commentary on
commercialism Romero then plunged ahead
with 1985's Day of the Dead which
condemns that U.S military's mice and
pension for shooting first and asking
questions later they are the dead takes
place in a bunker where a group of
scientists and soldiers tried to survive
and find a cure for the Zombie Plague
but it turns out the human threat is
almost as serious as a zombie one we
need each other can we just
the way I see it lady
I'm not so sure we need you at all
initially the film only pulled in a
worldwide total of five million dollars
against a 3.5 million dollar budget
according to Box Office Mojo however
according to pop matters it got
rejuvenated through home video platforms
including VHS and DVD Day of the Dead
gun and critical praise for Romero's and
flinching perception of society as well
as for its horrific Gore effects
produced by horror Legend Tom savini
while Romero continued his night to the
Living Dead series with more films over
the years Day of the Dead cupped off the
best Trilogy of the bunch
your next is a modern slasher film that
takes the scream in Halloween murder
games to the next level Aaron is a young
Australian woman who accompanies her
boyfriend Crispin Davidson to his family
reunion at the vacation home in Missouri
the family aren't exactly friendly or
agreeable with one another the four
longer Mass Killers begin assaulting the
home killing everyone one by one Aaron
attempts to survive the onslaught of
Terror with all the skills she has as
she gets to the bottom of the heinous
plan carried out against the Davidson
family the film features over-the-top
death traps and merciless assaults with
plenty of blood to go around your next
received mostly positive reviews from
the critics thanks for its fresh take on
the final gold Trope Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus praise the film in
particular calling it an energetic and
effective mix of brutal Gore and pitch
black humor I just think that is just
the height of the art form these days
however it didn't exactly land well at
the box office only making 26 million
dollars worldwide according to Box
Office Mojo the film has got some more
attention since his home video a release
and placement on various streaming
services like several of these beloved
cult horror films your next has
benefited from the modern convenience of
in-home streaming services which has
turned it into a modern slasher that
many people love it's also a notable
stepping stone and director Adam
wingard's career who's gone on to direct
much larger Productions such as Godzilla
vs Kong
John Carpenter's The Thing tells the
story of a hostile alien infiltrating a
crew in Antarctica on a microscopic
level the alien cells assimilate the
hosts they've infected and replace the
living organism cells with its own led
by McCready played by Kurt Russell the
crew attempts to figure out who's real
and who's a hideous alien in Disguise
the growing confusion creates an
unsettling fear and sense of anxiety and
Dread that's largely a matched in the
horror genre despite the film's status
as a horror Legend these days it was
instantly dismissed by critics upon its
release in 1982. many were put off by
the gore and practical effects that
accentuate the visceral grotesque's
horror of the alien thing and they
believe the film to be a soulless cash
in on the attraction to excess violence
in cinema furthermore the plot was
accused of being stale and too
simplistic Alan Spencer wrote for
starlog magazine that the thing is a
little more than two hours of makeup
test footage and heavily criticized
Carpenter for the film's lack of story
and vision evidently audiences were also
turned off by Carpenter's Body horror as
Box Office Mojo reports the film made
just 19.6 million dollars at the box
office in the Modern Age the film has
been regarded quite differently many
have Revisited its cultural impact on
horror with wired calling it a paranoid
classic and inverse claiming that it
raised a bar for sci-fi Guillermo del
Toro wrote a series of tweets praising
Carpenter and the thing writing the
irony is that most reviewers at the time
were entirely blind to the virtues of
story and character
Slither is an over-the-top black comedy
horror film directed and written by
James gern that does not disappoint in
the entertainment department whether you
come away from this flick hating it or
loving it there's never a dull moment a
meteorite introduces an Alien Parasite
into a small town in South Carolina
which promptly infects a man named grant
grant the alien assumes control of his
body and is able to hideously transform
and spell tentacles the possessed Grand
Grant abducts a woman and infects her
forcing her to breed alien lava when the
police get involved the townsfolk focus
on locating Grant and stopping the
transformation of local residents
although it was a critical success
Slither was a box office failure making
in only 12.8 million dollars against a
15 million dollar budget in fact the
report to the film's financial failure
was so abysmal that The Hollywood
Reporter speculated that the film May
spell the end for the horror comedy
sub-genre for quite some time in the
same article horror director Eli Roth
commented on the dicey nature of selling
a horror comedy film but he noted the
potential for longevity saying in 15
years nobody is going to be watching Ice
Age the Meltdown everybody is going to
be watching DVDs of Slither maybe we're
watching it on streaming services now
instead of DVD but he's not wrong it
only took a decade for retrospectives to
start churning out real evaluations of
the film with Publications like
Entertainment Weekly calling it a cult
classic
[Music]